Hi, I'm Cameron Pitman, and welcome to the class on AJAX requests.
Let's imagine that you want to visit a website.
When you type in the name of the website into your browser and
press Enter, what do you expect to happen?
The exact answer, of course, depends on the website.
But it's safe to say that you expect to see,
well, something, some website, to show up very quickly.
And have you noticed how
the next page button has mostly disappeared from the Internet?
Modern websites can load content without reloading.
Developers have solved the challenge of loading information quickly and
after the first page render in many ways.
And one flexible and popular implementation relies on AJAX requests,
which allow for data to be received asynchronously.
Data that loads asynchronously can be requested late in the load process and
the website should load acceptably with or without it.
As part of this class, you'll be building a move planner app.
You know what?
Let's take a look at it.